empeora el estado de salud de alexéi
navalni el líder opositor ruso ha sido
trasladado a la enfermería de la prisión
tiene fiebre alta y tos esta mañana se
le ha practicado una prueba de
coronavirus la opositora la ex ineban
link empezó la semana pasada una huelga
de hambre denunciando que las
autoridades penitenciarias rusas no
permitían a su médico personal que
accediese a las instalaciones desde hace
semanas se queja de dolores en una
pierna y también en la espalda y
denuncia que en la cárcel no está siendo
tratado de manera adecuada también en
los últimos días ha denunciado que
existe un brote de tuberculosis en el
pabellón en el que ahora mismo está
internado hoy ha intentado acceder a la
cárcel su doctora personal y no lo ha
conseguido en el entorno de la prisión
se han concentrado también seguidores de
alexéi navalni exigiendo la liberación
del líder opositor